The upside to working in the main news. Well. I think each of us gets a certain amount of q. Docs.
For being involved name in news. Can something we can talk about without the paypal is and doesn't involve.
Somebody else's life or somebody has got to or. You know the usual gossip.
Getting chasing because there's nothing else to talk about.
But yeah something interesting to talk about is always something happening in these.
And we would develop you know ideas and and skills and. All the rest of it.
And the name and uses the how people really do support it in. It's not really that hard to sell the advertising and.
All that we are the cheapest around that it's still the cheapest yeah for sure. Yeah. Well you know much.
We know and people. You know it's really good. You know it's the best one yet.
Well they've traded it lockets in order to say which a surprise easy know why.
It is an odd price it's very different from anyone else's. It's got some many good points to it.
And it's good it's bad points too you know i mean people are people they're going to be nasty sometimes.
But there's so many good things happening here that.
He's a very interesting place to be i suppose it's especially working from this office. It's infinitely interesting.
How often doing it. Between night knowing nice. In the main. Well there's not a place like is there. I really believed.
The ideals that was just batted. About it.
You know the peace love and brown grass and came back tonight sure than what i saw as the things that is.
Simplistic why of. Saying name been has changed for me it's not the same anymore.
There's certain amount of disillusionment. As far as the human nature part of it is concerned but.
That's more to do is my expectations dain anything to do i mean.
Human beings have been human beings for how long i should have got the message by now. And i have. You know i mean.
But then i hadn't. And i sort of. Thought he was going to be. How i thought it was going to pay. But it was how it is.
You know i mean. It was it was. Why i was there and. That's what you know that's right. When im been. Nimbin is.
Chinese. With they all the stresses and strains and. Experiences that naman is had. You can only really pay.
How it's evolved. And it's evolved into what it is now. So we had to. See what it is now that.
Just walking around town and saying i saw it. It would hand shape. You know lots of people us a people smiling.
You realize that. Yeah. Ok we've all got the docs eyes on the downsides of lofted on the how you know.
Quite a heavy price. And it's. What you know make a lot of companies pay for anybody else.
I mean i they don't take much notice but. I think people always pick on what i don't understand and.
Whatever new going oh you're trying to put out over.
When you sing eternity if he's going to be attacked from all sides because he switches in the given order. Whatever's.
Existing for everybody else out there he says all i know. And. If you china have something a little bit different.
But it's not that much different. Then. It's going to be attacked.
It's going to be brought down it's going to be misrepresented. It's going to be laughed at skin of a school and.
So i sings.
It's other people's reactions to naming it's not really anything to do with naming that
and say it was different because i just. Moved out of a marriage. So it was going to be different anyway.
It was very different. I had to try and i have a cow. Living around.
I mean a lot and really and i own a loan and know having next one i have use. So much and stuff like that.
And i decided i count. I think libyans are very social beings i knock a little bit a balance and balance is one.
I don't think maybe that's something i still want to learn but it hasn't. I haven't accomplished it yet. So.
Yeah yeah yeah so life in. Only difficulties was really. I mean. I just i think i wasn't so tall at that stage.
All the difficulties were pounced on with glee. If you like the the. The tics and late she's ha ha ha you know.
Yeah it's a tic i have. You know you sort of. Think it's a big guy there.
And this just shows how how you roughing it and. You know all that all that sort of stuff. Now the tics and you since.
It was oh yeah. Well it was for me i can't speak for anybody else i mean.
Maybe other people that i had different expectations and ideas that i went to stop this from yeah. Ok so you know..
So it's just one t. Yeah. Yeah i'm glad to see it and i came to the area.
A month after the aquarius festival came to me in. And i lived around noon been in many places for three years. And.
And then became body found. Pygame part of body found when it started when we moved here nine hundred seventy seven.
And the reason that we got this place was because of the meditation center.
Up the road which many of us had helped to build and found and we wanted very much to be close to that.
At that time we felt that. Meditation practice was a really important part of all of our lives.
And yet we wanted to raise families and so on so we thought we'd have a sort of like. Community. Yeah yeah. Yes.
Well many of us had lived in india travelled in the east.
Some of the people who formed this community had virtually come directly from india.
And in fact came to the area because christopher to miss. Who gave the first retreated the meditation.
And that was really their main interest. You know lives at that time. When the very most important thing. So.
We'd all had a lot of experience in but his practice and.
Just wanted to share that in mutual support in that practice was what we felt we could have here. He does go. You know.
Kay describing body farm. It's a hundred and fifty acres. Much of which is at a forty five degree. A greater angle.
With lots of forest. When we came here the trees.
They regrouped was about twenty five years old the trees continue to grow taller and taller.
We have very little cleared land really just enough for chewed. And guidance. And we've got. About thirteen dwellings.
Going along to. Two little roads. Most couples or single people have their own shelters.
There's some arrangements where various facilities are shared i i have a set of exploding house that i share.
With my present husband. My son his two sons and. Another woman and her daughter.
So there's lots of different living arrangements.
And then we have this wonderful large community center which we built together some years ago.
Where we get together for dinner. Kasia lee and i parties and meetings. Play together here.
Can't quite seen him been hidden by the heels but it's really very close as the close. Crow flies.
Is a lovely time to will creek down. The bottom of our property.
And we've got another community on one side is a neighbor's and. So sort of commercial operation on the other. So yes.
There wasn't a single shelter here there's a bit of a floor.
From some house that had been chainsawed to bits and taken away.
I lived with my partner at that time in a fifteen foot caravan. Mack ensued lived in a team. And. Down the road.
There were two other guys i guess they must have been intense that was about it.
At the beginning there was about four of us.
And we just straight away had to build a shelter where we could cook and stuff. So we did that in a very piecemeal way.
None. None of us. Had virtually any experience in building. And being very sort of. Idealistic about making it.
Our own way we had no power tools we did all our buildings by hand. Everything by hand. Lot of work.
And a lot of learning. Which is quite fantastic that we took that. We had no water. No nothing and.
It's interesting that in the first year just heaps of people flocked to hear.
I think by the time we were two years old we had thirty people staying here under the most difficult conditions and.
A tiny tiny communal space in which we ate together every day.
And we had eight babies in the first year eight babies in tents mine was born in the caravan and.
So we were busy having babies in building at very basic houses at the same time. It was quite.
It was quite stressful and quite challenging and we had a tremendous sense of helping each other.
People were drawn because they. I mean we immediately had a reputation is a spiritual community.
Which can work both ways people can say very nice things about you know very scathing things about you.
And we've had plenty of. And i'm sure we deserve. You know if you. If you set yourself up.
To have a lot of ideals here are really good. Agate.
But yes a lot of those people who are really interested in meditation practice or buddhism.
You know something like that was what drew them here.
I think that we were very lucky in that the people who began this community it was like a good chemical mixture.
It worked in there was really very little conflict and that attracted people as well.
Well i'd say we experimented with there were inquiry into the basic buddhist precepts switch involve you know killing
no stealing. Issue. Of what's called. False speech no full speech which is truly trying to be as truthful as possible.
Not taking. Intoxicants which was never totally strict but. Was quite strict.
Early on things like that and we also expected everyone to do a retreat every year
and that if someone wanted to join the community that they really needed to know what that was about. So.
To do a retreat was important. Not early on did we fight. Many other teachers around but.
In the later years we've had some wonderful. Spiritual teachers come here. Like teach not. On his feet and me.
The man who we built the meditation center for to teach in comes back he was here again this here christopher.
So we have a very much an ongoing relationship with him. And we've organized. Retreats for being alive.
Sort of in the lineage of christian marriage he and numerous other. Teaches. So.
That was very very obvious at the beginning. It's not like when you were not unique in that diamond and.
Across the ridge. Also has a very strong orientation towards what his spiritual practice to do. Yeah.
It was quite strict i mean when you. So many of his first met. These ideas in india.
Or nepal someplace like that in the idea. What does it mean not to. Any living thing that seem possible but.
Yes i mean in the beginning we didn't kill mosquitoes which bitterness and. When blowflies.
Bit as not blowflies much flies because we didn't kill them we simply tried to rattle their brains.
You know hand so they didn't trouble us too much. And it. I mean.
It's easy to move be cynical or scoff at that now but it's really quite interesting to play with ideas
and see how far you can go with that and. And that's true with.
Looking at all those precepts and i think what we came to. Within a few years was that. There's no actual action or.
Non action that has to be adhered to but that you're conscious all the time of what you're doing.
And more and more that. I think become a shared. Inquiry. Used to really be willing to just say ok well.
Is this really something what i want to do and
when i kill this creature am i aware of it is it necessary is that you know.
Just really thinking about what we do in our lives. Yeah yeah. That's the millet that guy uses that word into.
Instead of meditation and i think everybody here would agree that that's what we're.
That's what you nine says use a dedication to. Inquiring for us selves and.
To share that and to acknowledge it it's a bit different for everybody. But it's really good to share it and.
And have other people reflect back to you how they feel about your inquiry to. You. Yeah.
One of our main claims to fame and i must say that. Being attacked by the government.
Even on the local level it's like an outside threat is a wonderful thing to unite a community and.
My memory may not be as clear as some other people here on that but.
When the fight for the trainee a creek rain forest. Came to a head of course body found many other places around where.
Deserted everyone was down there.
And the local community in some ways took that struggle as a real affront to something that they thought was there is
and.
It was only at that stage that the local council said hey wait a minute you never asked for permission to build on this
land we've never even heard of you. I mean they had to have known. We were doing or were doing but that was.
They just had had enough. With their troublemaking and.
Suddenly said you can't do that and the whole movement from multiple occupancy. So to spring from that conflict.
And a lot of people here were very active in that movement. And in the. What it ended up. Ended up.
Being with the family was that we had demolition demolition nobody's put on to other houses.
Primarily because they didn't have four walls they had three will. Before that there was a lot of question of whether.
We had the right to that our building standards weren't good enough and.
Sydney uni and all kinds of people got involved with testing. The strength of our timbers meeus found out that room.
Round poles are ever so much stronger than a similar thickness of square poles and so on
but in the end we had a demolition order and. Two houses for five years.
Which eventually went to the land and environment court and. We all really enjoyed hearing.
Whatever you call it happened. One of those houses was mine and and.
I look back now and i would feel the same way if it was done over again i'm. I can remember saying to my partner well.
Let's build the bleachers for the audience to watch this place being full does you know how fantastic. Because in fact.
When we all went all of us first. Built here. A very important idea to us was to do minimally.
And to create something where we wouldn't be too tied up into material positions that a house wasn't.
Didn't take a huge investment of time and money. In therefore you have to worry about it.
And that's in the spirit which we approached. That conflict was. Not being terribly worried if we lost.
That it would be quite a good bit of theatre and. Quite a statement. But in fact it did you know and to us and.
We learnt a lot and we became very involved in the community. Because of that. Yeah. Yes. And is a room not a room.
Yeah. And i mean that the questions that the council q c. Put was. You know. Well.
I mean this is terrible what about the welfare of children. Roman snakes coming in. Our q see question what's sleep.
Verandah and lismore if it's got a television and a bed in it. And so it was very interesting. From time. Right here.
You mean in men and women's relationships. I don't know if.
I don't think the actual physical stress is that we underwent such as not having a stove or. Hot water. Or a bathroom.
Or a place to wash nappies. Really was a strain on our relationships. It was. I think a big.
Internal strain for individuals. Because it was like i mean we didn't. None of us grew up in communities. People don't.
In the western world and.
You have to learn all kinds of things which you don't have to know about when you live in a nuclear situation.
So in that way it was very stressful in the fact that.
Things that every family have to do such as nappies is quite a huge job when you don't have much to do it with.
And yet. We had to build our houses and. Cook for thirty people every day.
And no telephone we had to drive the channon to make a phone call and all that sort of thing is.
That's sort of what i meant by stress. Will a lot of.
I'm wondering if i can say if there's any single relationship which remained intact over the period of this community
which is now fifteen years. And i think no. But that is not unlike. People our age. In the wider community.
Some of us have established relationships with people who. On the community. You know like. You could say.
People have changed partners really not quite like that but.
Yes people who have lived here
and dissolve relationships have made new ones with other people i mean this is so cool but it's going to come out.
Well. I don't know a lot about other communities. I thought i think they have a feeling that we communicate.
Really well. Of course there are tensions between us. People.
You know we see things differently want things to be done differently. But we've always managed to get through it with.
Real crises. And. Yes it is. We don't leave all that close together. Really moment to moment.
So that's not a really big problem. But just like.
You know i shared a house in the city or anything like most of most of the time i in fact have shared my my.
Shelter with other couples or people in two people in a child or one person and child. And yes that stressful.
But i think lots of people experience. This tresses who don't live in communities to. Students. You know.
It's very much the same. Well. The place was incredibly cheap. It wasn't a real hot property.
It was color it's called rubbish by the locals because it's all trees and scape.
So it was only sixteen thousand dollars and. We decided at the beginning that there'd be one thousand dollars.
So it didn't take long for us to pay for that and.
It was only after a number of years when we realized that for new people joining.
That maybe the share price should go up.
At the moment i think it's still under four thousand dollars for a share it's just very had someone to get us to agree
that they can be a shareholder. Destruction is that we set up. We set ourselves up in the cheap.
Legally in the cheapest way possible which was a company which was sort of. Under a voluntary association.
Because that's a very very cheap way of forming an organisation much cheaper
and simpler than a cooperative so we were a voluntary association. We called ourselves the bloody church.
Churches are voluntary associations and formed a company. And we have. Trustees. Of the land is held in trust but what.
What a voluntary association means that the place cannot be sold it has to be passed on to another such organisation
and that was one of our big ideals was that. Ok.
We're going to get a hold of this in this piece of land can never be bought and sold again.
We decided that shares were. Non-refundable.
And that everything here belong to the community so technically speaking our houses do not belong to us.
They go along to the community. Day to day organization evolved and.
We've got it down pretty well like in the beginning we only had communal cause we had a car a system a car booking
system. Cars had parents who looked you know looked after them. One person did the food ordering another person.
When we did get a telephone. Did the telephone bill. Someone else took care of the car books.
And that's all still in place today. And that's. It wasn't always easy but i think a lot of people would say.
We felt really good. Figuring those things out. So that they were it. We pay into our general kitty. Every week.
We save money. We decide on major expenditures together we operate. I suppose you'd say consensus minus one.
We don't vote. Sometimes we spend an awful lot of time talking about things like.
We might talk when we were going to build a dam we talked about it for about three years every reading. And then.
We switched to some other thorny subject which. You know.
And sometimes i think our meetings are so long is just because we really do like to talk.
And we were too sort of active to do it socially so we only had meetings as excuses to talk for a long time so that.
You know we've just develop strategies for dealing with the stress of it.
Like i can remember early on i get headache side be shaking i feel exhausted irritable after meetings and.
A lot of us is. You know where you sit not being so. It's a one.
Community is a wonderful way of learning not to be so invested in your own opinions.
Because if you have a big investment of that is just how much trouble you can give me. Yeah i do. Yeah.
I do think everyone has had to deal with that and it's gotten a lot out of it. Ok.
You know i when i hear about it it is being studied now so often.
Really likely based which is i mean it's fine it's obviously. Because i'm here for.
Finding a way to live that doesn't tie to the tyranny of. Working. You know. Your life away and.
But i think the same time i.
I wonder how easy you know how hard a time communities can have like that that i just threw up.